the other thing you should do if you're
not very industrious
industrious is discipline yourself and
so what do you do with that
eat three times a day at regular meal
times that's a good thing to practice
because that starts to put some
stability into your life get up at the
same time i would highly recommend all
those young people out there who are
listening like you want to get a jump on
life get the hell out of bed in the
morning you know as i've got older i've
got up earlier and earlier now that's
partly because you don't need as much
sleep but it's also partly because i've
got more and more discipline
like
get up early in the morning and get your
things done man learn to get up at six
in the morning and you'll be one deadly
creature especially if you can get to
work you'll have half your damn day done
by the time other people haul their
sorry asses out of bed and so that's a
massive massive advantage look will
ferrell
warren farrell not the comedian warren
farrell the author he outlined data in
why men earn more which is a book i
would recommend by the way showing that
if you work 13 longer hours you make 40
percent more money
it's non-linear so you think why is that
well imagine you had 10 employees and
one of them works an extra 10 percent
it's not much
well how often is that person going to
be
promoted assuming you have a clue as a
boss
it's like you're going to look at the 10
people and you're going to think oh that
guy's always here like 45 minutes early
it's like why don't we give him the
promotion obviously right so these tie
these small edges that you can manage
like that work an extra 10 percent extra
13 percent have non-proportional payoffs
that's part of the pareto distribution
so
get
get your sleep cycle organized so you
get up in the morning learn how to do it
no excuses i'm too tired in the morning
i don't like mornings who cares that's
not relevant it's like discipline
yourself so you can manage it
schedule your meals because that's a
good disciplinary routine
and then learn to use a calendar like
google calendar most of you many of you
out there do not use a calendar okay a
calendar is not a prison and it's not a
tyrant not if you use it properly
a calendar keeps anxiety at bay it makes
sure that you do what you need to do
which is important because otherwise you
fall behind but if you use it properly
though it's also
helps you plan what you want to do so i
could say well lay out your damn
calendar
and
design the days you would like to have
that's what your calendar is for so you
can put in all sorts of things in there
you want to do and that would be good
for you and that's a really good
really good way to start being more
industrious
make a plan you need a plan for three
years
you need a plan for the next year you
need to plan for the next six months you
need to plan for the next three months
you need a plan for the week you need a
plan for the day you need to plan for
the hour
all of that all of that i make lists
constantly of what i have to do and
they're like daily weekly monthly yearly
right now i can't look out more than
about six months you know because my
life is too complicated and chaotic but
but you need a vision of who you could
be what character you could have three
to five years out you can't go much
farther than that because life is too
unpredictable i think to
make vision that's longer term than that
subject to
there's too much chance associated with
it to spend a lot of time on maybe you
can stretch it to five years and in rare
cases you can have a 10-year goal but it
has to be pretty low resolution but you
want plans at all those levels of
resolution you want to write the things
down and what because what are you going
to do you're going to stumble around and
get get what you need you're going to
stumble around and be useful to other
people and it's useful to be useful to
other people you know they want to work
with you then they want to do things
with you they want to have you around
they trust you they open up
opportunities for you and if you stumble
around like you're blind you're not
going to get anywhere and then you're
going to suffer and then you're going to
be bitter and then you're going to be
cruel
so that's a that's hell that's a bad
outcome want to be happy build a life
not just the business hey it's evan
carmichael and this channel is created
to help you overcome the number one
challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too you've got
michael jordan level genius at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and get some of the greatest
lessons for young people
enjoy
[Music]
lesson number two pay the price today
with grant cardone pay the price today
okay learn to discipline yourself if you
got to go to the gym every day if you
hate going to the gym go to the gym i
don't like going to the gym but i'm like
i don't like my body hurting either
sooner or later if you don't go to the
gym and work your body your body will
it will scream at you and it will hurt
lower back pains arms shoulders knees
you name it it's always going to hurt
and as long as it's hurting how can you
be fully available for the people around
you if your body's certain two you gotta
eat good foods okay gotta make decisions
i ain't gonna eat junk
i'm not gonna eat the junk why why
because i'm saying no to junk
if you can start saying no to stuff
you can start saying yes to the good
things like my little girl right there
sabrina say hi sabrina
so pay the price today learn how to be
great at jobs you hate
that's paying the price get up early go
to bed early okay beat the sun up every
morning it'll give you so much
confidence i'm paying the price when i
do that when i get up before the sun
gets up i'm paying the price when i go
to bed at nine o'clock and i'm not
watching tv and movies and just being
entertained and effective whatever's
coming my way i'm paying the price
when i don't waste the weekends the
weekends make you weak listen to me
weekends are for weak people
anything after 10 o'clock at night it's
for weak people
okay saturday and sunday staying up all
night wheat people people are made weak
on the weekends
pay the price okay give up the weekends
for the next
five years
and watch what happens five years man
that's a lot of weekends that's what is
that 250 weekends is that right yeah 250
weekends that means i'm ahead of the
people around me
i'm paying the price today
in hopes that i could pay any price in
the future so that when you have a
family okay
when you find that person that you love
and want to take care of
when you finally get the right job and
the credibility and the trust in the
marketplace when you finally believe in
yourself completely
you'll also have the rewards and the
fruits necessary
so that you can start paying for the
things that you and your family have now
earned and deserve lesson number three
make progress now with ed mylett if
you've got the desire to win if you want
to be somebody if you want to make your
dreams come true i don't care if you're
12 years old or 82 years old your age is
irrelevant it's a form of ageism to tell
a young person just be patient if you're
like me my mom and my dad didn't give me
a business i didn't start on second or
third base like some of these people
that are telling you somehow to be
patient i had to pick myself up by my
bootstraps and make something of my life
and frankly the sooner you get going the
sooner you start working on yourself the
sooner you make progress the sooner
you're going to get there and enjoy your
life and so don't listen to that crap
think about this when i was in my 20s i
made six figures early in my 20s by the
time i was 30 i was making seven figures
by the time i was 40 i was earning an
eight figure income what if somebody had
told me ah cool it be patient don't
worry about it my entire life would be
different i wouldn't be looking at the
ocean living oceanfront now or flying on
my jet or taking care of my parents or
having multiple homes living on the lake
having multiple boats multiple cars
whatever the material things are
donating to the charities that i want
and i listen to that absurd ridiculous
stupid advice so please don't listen to
those people
who tell you that they have good
intentions they're talking about not
putting pressure on yourself you've got
all kinds of time the truth is a little
pressure is probably pretty good for you
think about this steve jobs was in his
20s and teens when he started bill gates
mark cuban kylie jenner you taught any
entrepreneur that's out there today that
you know pretty well most of them
started young jay-z started young lebron
james started young why is it that you
can't start young
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there lesson number four attack the life
that you want with gary vaynerchuk this
is the time to realize that you have a
five-year window and it's three for some
it's eight for others but there's a
five-year window for you to attack the
life that you want to win not because
it's the secret or because the world's
so zen because it's hard to [ __ ] out
there as a matter of fact i'm probably
more scared about your naivete to how
hard
class is easy right what you've been
doing for the last 16 years is easy it's
a [ __ ] game it's structured it's
easy the world this thing
this thing is hard
however
that contradicts what i'm gonna tell you
right now which is this is the best and
easiest five years of your life because
this is when you need to attack what you
love and what you want to do here's why
you don't have all the baggage you may
have college loans respect it's hard
you may have the expectations of your
parents mentally hard fake hard you may
have a lot of other things but this is
exactly when you can live with four
roommates in a basement and eat fast
food do you understand this is not when
the baby's there some of your babies
this is not when you've been married and
you promised this is not when the world
has sucked out all your dreams and hopes
yet
you still got this window and yet so
many of you are so hungry for short-term
short-term gains like maximizing the job
that paid you three thousand dollars
more but it's not as fun but you want
that three thousand dollars for what
for what for a new iphone for what you
get to live life one time and this is
the time right now to understand what's
actually happening
and actually map your behavior to
something that will impact you for the
next 80 years so promise me
promise me all you youngsters that are
watching this right now in the comments
because i'll jump in and talk to you
promise me that you understand that the
land grab of happiness
starts right now that you don't have to
worry about getting that job what you
should do is
go and travel and learn go and start
that business that you've always wanted
hook up with those three teammates and
start that band you've always wanted
this is the time to be massively risk
massively risk oriented i know that this
is when you're supposed to grow up and
go see the world but guess what the
world isn't what mommy and daddy told
you the world is exactly going to be
what it's going to be with or without
the way you thought it was going to be a
ton of [ __ ] is going to change the world
changes every god damn day right now
what you need to recognize is you can
afford to
and not all of you i'm sure somebody
will leave a comment and say i've got a
loan i get it respect but that loan is
going to be there whether you go and try
to build something for yourself or not
one way or the other and by the way you
can work at night this is when you put
in the 18 hours a day to make your life
that you want happen and again because
i'm scared i can hear myself talking i'm
not saying it's the secret it's
practicality when you are in your early
20s this is when you can grind at your
highest levels because there isn't all
the
baggage that comes across your life it's
harder for the 42 year olds that are
watching right now to listen to this
advice you can't just wake up tomorrow
and be like let's go because little
sally has soccer practice and because
you've got a million other things that
are holding you down but boy
if you're lucky enough to be graduating
today with not a [ __ ] idea of what
you're gonna do with your future
nobody's ever been luckier than you
please recognize it lesson number five
be careful who you hang out with with
eric thomas i need you to be careful of
the environment you're in and the people
you're running with
and i'm not mad at you but just make
sure that the people you're with are
taking you where you want to go so if
you're trying to go to jail keep running
with my man that's where you're trying
to go if you're trying to die early go
forward i'm saying that's what you're
trying to do you're trying to get
pregnant before you're 17. keep fooling
with my man
i i don't know what you're trying to do
i'm not trying to tell you what to do
but i'm saying that the group of people
you hanging with
[Applause]
you better be careful who you're hanging
with cause they taking you somewhere bro
the person you hang out with can change
your life forever who you hanging out
with
who you running with you running with
people going to jail i'm not against
that
i just know when i got caught with my
boy with the dope and we went to jail we
didn't go to prison we went to jail for
a couple days i realized that it was a
toilet in the middle of the
i knew then didn't say i didn't say my i
can't do this
it was dudes like actually using the
bathroom in front of people i was like
bro i don't care if i'm here today four
days friday i'm holding i'm holding
everything they was bringing in nasty
food dudes was like let me get yours i'm
like here you can have it
they was eating like it was mcdonald's
you laughing but they had gotten
accustomed to being prisoners
they got accustomed to their freedom
being taken
i went one time and was like yo this
ain't for me i ain't meant to be i'm not
meant to be bunking with no dude forever
i ain't mad at nobody but that ain't i'm
not meant to be telling bedtime me and
my man tell the story for 30 years
together it's top bunk i'm in the bottom
but i'm like that ain't my life i got
married at 19. i've been sleeping with
my girl since i was 19 years old i
wasn't meant to be in prison i wasn't
meant to miss thanksgiving with my
grandma i wasn't meant to miss uh uh
fourth of july i would that's that's not
the life i was meant for
i was meant to have my freedom i was
meant to travel the world i got a
passport
what's your life meant for and how
important is your life to you how much
do you value it
this is your time guys
i should tell my kids when they was in
school it's your job this your only job
what you're doing right now is going to
determine where you go next and where
you go next is going to determine the
rest of your life you ain't going to be
a teenager but for a few years watch
this 13 14 15 16 17 18 19. that's seven
years it seemed like it's gonna last
forever but it's not
you'll be a teenager for 17 seven years
you'll be an adult for the rest of your
life
but the decisions you make in those
seven years will determine what the rest
of your life looks like and lesson
number six the last one before some very
special bonus clips is open your eyes
with satguru i want to open your eyes
and look at the world
right now please see
what is the most needed thing in the
world right
now you don't do some fanciful thing
that you like to do you must do what's
most needed isn't it
isn't it
if you get carried away by situations
people become like this it's useful but
it is not the basic thing
today you saw a train burning
so you want to become a firefighter
tomorrow you saw something
you want to become that
in reaction in emotional reaction you
choose to become something it could be
useful on some level
but now
when most young people cannot think
you're thinking
what should i do with my life
when such a thought has come i would say
spend little more time on it
not being influenced by anybody
or anything simply look at it what is it
that the humanity needs most
what is it that the world needs most
today i want you to
recognize that
the only thing that needs to be fixed
on this planet as human beings
everything else is fine isn't it so
so
i would say
all young people not just you
must take a break from what you're doing
just caught up because you did you did
school you went to college because you
did college you went to the next thing
and the next thing and you end up
with a phd what to do
it's dangerous you know
because the education scientists are
saying if you go through 20 years of
formal education and land up with a phd
or something
70 of your intelligence is irrevocably
destroyed
yes
you become a very knowledgeable idiot
and today knowledge has no use because
whatever
a phd holder knows
a high school kid can open the internet
and talk the same language
you can't even look smart anymore
with what you collected
isn't it
because just about anybody will talk
these things because it's all over the
place
so are you preparing for a university
or the universe
that's where you have to live
unless you want to become an academic
i'm not saying these things are wrong
but human beings sensible human beings
must invest their life towards what is
needed most isn't it
not some fanciful thing that i want to
do or you want to do
you can do whatever
joyfully or miserably isn't it
and just because
today you think
by doing this i will be happy
if you go
don't ever think you will stay happy by
doing that after some time
everybody when they got their first job
what a beautiful day it was
you went to this
mandy little office
sat there and wow
how it felt
but after a few years sitting behind the
same table
it's taking your life
the same job the same marriage the same
situations
they're taking your life but one day
they look like heaven after some time it
looks like hell isn't it
not because there's something wrong with
those jobs simply because you're doing
it for the wrong reason
you're just doing it for the wrong
reasons that's all
now that you're thinking i would say
take a few weeks off
be willing to give you the space just
stay uninfluenced by anybody just look
at it
there are many things you will want to
do right now
because of immediate compulsions
you're broke right now you think the
first thing is to find a job
or some other compulsion within you you
think the first thing is to do this
beside your compulsions suppose you had
none of these compulsions what would you
like to do with life that's what you
should do
you should not decide your life and the
course of your life based on immediate
compulsions
you decide in your life
if you do this for 100 years and look
back
after 100 years if you look back is it
still worthwhile
you do that
there are many others who would like to
be you
oh i wish i was 20 and i wish i could
think what to do at that time i did
something
there any number of people here
now that you're 20
and you're fortunate that you're
thinking
and it's fortunate that you're here
it's time you think straight before you
do anything
you need to apply every day to do
something in your business 30 to 60
minutes at least every single day and
this is for anybody anybody who who has
a life outside of their business whether
you have a job whether you're in high
school whether in university whether
you're doing something else you have
this dream that you want to go out and
do but you have a lot of other
responsibilities and often what you'll
find is those things take away from your
time to actually run your business and
so you need to make sure that you're
taking action every single day that
you're building momentum for your
business for your idea even if you don't
know what the the next best step is
because there is no perfect steps in
building a business there's a lot of
stuff that you have to do and test and
try and build momentum for but making
sure that you're putting the time in
because i think too many people spend
too much time up here too much time
thinking and making the perfect plan and
and not enough time actually doing you
got to get out and actually do and make
time for it consistently 30 to 60
minutes every single day on your
business to start building momentum
put in let's get it i was
living in london and attending law
school i was becoming disillusioned with
the law
i happened to be dating a girl who was
in advertising she said you might like
advertising and boom i have a career in
marketing like i fell into it so many of
us fall into our careers in full entire
jobs and even if we do
pursue something we want to do sometimes
it takes diversions right this is this
is what i mean by living our lives by
accident which is we largely leave the
direction of our careers and sometimes
even our own happiness to others our
bosses and you know all of that thing
so what it means to live your life on
purpose means you understand the
direction you're heading but you remain
agnostic as to the root most people try
very very hard to plan the route in
other words what's your plan people say
well first i'm going to work here for
three years then i'm going to quit and
i'm going to do this and then for four
years and they got the root plan and the
question is where are you going right
and that to me is what it means to have
purpose it means to have destination
right it's like waking up in the morning
and saying i'm going on holiday somebody
says where are you going said i'm going
on vacation i told you you're like where
are you going vacation
right um and so how are you going to get
there you're like well i'm taking route
95. so you've got the route planned but
you have no destination and you see this
in companies all the time you know why
does your company exist growth
great why are you growing why do you
need to grow what does growth mean
because we're a company we have to grow
and so they figure out all of these
paths for growth but they don't know
where they're going i would rather
someone wake up in the morning and say
california i'm trying to get to
california and i don't care what route i
take i'm going to start down route 95
and if i find a better route i'm going
to take it if there's traffic on route
95 i'm going to take a side road so this
is what happened in my career people
kept telling me that i was unfocused
because i kept taking side roads i
wasn't unfocused i was going around
obstacles
so that's what it means to live a life
of purpose it means i live every single
day of my life trying to get to an end
point in my case to create a world in
which the vast majority of people wake
up every single morning inspired to go
to work feel safe when they're there and
return home at the end of the day
fulfilled by the work that they do
that is the destination i'm trying to
reach i don't know how i'm going to get
there but i'm going to try every path i
can to get there highly highly focused
that's what it means to live a life on
purpose we're often given this advice
like do what you love yeah like what am
i supposed to do yes like find your
passion like thank you like great like i
don't know what to do tomorrow
for me passion is the result of
something right so if you work hard for
something you don't believe in that's
called stress and if you work for so
hard for something you do believe in
that's called passion so it's finding
the belief it's finding the cause it's
finding the purpose and the passion then
shows up so it's not about doing
something with passion and then finding
the cause it's finding the cause
starting with why and then the passion
is what is what results i was working
once in an ice cream parlor when i was
about 15 years old
my first real job
and on the second day
i was asked to scrape the gum
off between the mexican tiles on the
floor and i said to the woman who owned
the store it was called goosai screen
parlor you didn't hire me to scrape gum
you hired me
to scoop ice cream and there's this girl
in the shoe store across the way that's
looking at me i don't want to see him
scraping the gum
and she said what are you talking about
i own this store i'll do any anything i
want with you get down on your knees and
scrape that gum
and i said i'm not doing it
she said you're fired
last job i ever had
i owe that woman
everything
i don't like to work for people
many of you would hear i hope inherit
that
there's nothing wrong with it
if you want to control your own destiny
you work for yourself
that's how it works i'm trying to
inspire those of you who are on the
tipping point
take the chance you're young
go for it
there's nothing
better
than being able to wake up in the
morning
10 years or 20 years from now and do
whatever
you
like
it's about freedom
that's what matters
i'm not saying being an employee is bad
but believe me
being an entrepreneur is better
[Music]
i'm a little biased
did you know you wanted to do this when
you were a kid yes well not this
particular expedition
but it's a very good question you know
ever since i was five years old that's
when neil armstrong stepped onto the
surface of the moon i've been um kind of
passionate about space rockets rocket
engines space travel i became a science
fiction reader
and i've always known that i wanted to
do something having to do with space and
i've spent a lot of time thinking about
it for really almost my whole life and
that's one of the things you guys will
find
that you have passions and having a
passion is a gift i think we all have
passions and you don't get to
choose them they pick you but you have
to be alert to them you have to be
looking for them and when you find your
passion it's a fantastic gift for you
because it gives you direction it gives
you purpose
you can have a job or you can have a
career or you can have a calling and the
best thing is to have a calling and if
you find your passion you'll have that
and all your work won't feel like work
to you so what advice do you give to
someone who's eight years old who wants
to put content up and of all the haters
that make comment and just like destroy
his fears so hard
so tough
it's horrible it's horrible when my mom
goes i want to do vlogs my mom vlogs
guys she's got like 700 000 subscribers
this is my mother she's 55.
when she goes i want to do vlogs i'm
like mom you have no idea
the internet is going to tear you apart
she's like no i'm fine
a week later calls me sobbing
logan you won't believe what these
people are saying about me
are my wrinkles really that bad
am i not funny i'm like mom i told you
you gotta have iron skin but as an
eight-year-old it's hard to have iron
skin
because you're eight
so
i'd say i'd say if
you gotta if you know you to be a
youtuber and an influencer just know
that hate is coming the negative
comments are when i had acne in college
when i was doing vines and like i get
comments like you look like a burn
victim whatever and i'm like
like they heard me
but at the end of the day who cares
there's like five of them saying that
how old are you
um
okay
so wait you have to tell everyone that
because i if i repeat it you think i'm
lying okay
six and three quarters yeah
love those fractions yes
okay if you're asking those questions
now
you'll be the deepest thinking adult
there ever was
so so what is the meaning of life i
think
people
[Music]
ask that question
on the assumption
that meaning is something you can look
for
and then i found it
here's the meaning here's what it is
i've been looking for it okay and it
doesn't
consider the possibility
that maybe meaning in life is something
that you
create
you manufacture for yourself
and for others
and so when i think of meaning in life
i ask
have i learned something today that i
didn't know yesterday
bringing me a little closer
to knowing all that can be known in the
universe just a little closer however
far away all the knowledge sits i'm a
little closer
if i live a day and i don't know a
little more that day than the day before
i think i wasted that day
so the people who at the end of the
school year say
the summer i don't have to think anymore
i'm thinking what is
what
what
the to learn is to
become closer
to nature
and to learn how things work gives you
power to influence
events
gives you power to help people who may
need it
power to help yourselves to shape a
trajectory so when i think of what is
the meaning of life
to me that's not an eternal unanswerable
question
to me that is in arms reach of me every
day
and so for you
at age six and three quarters
i may i suggest that
for you you should explore nature as
much as you possibly can and
occasionally that means
getting your clothes dirty because you
might want to jump into puddles and your
parents don't want you to do that
you tell them that i gave you permission
[Music]
you know what else
[Music]
you know what else
[Music]
so
i'll give you more permission for more
things you ready
okay
um
have you ever
pulled all the pots and pans out of the
cabinet before and hit them with the
wooden spoon have you done that yet
[Music]
have you done that
he said in a way
what did your parents say when you when
you did that
oh you did it with paper plates that's
not nearly as fun as drawing with the
pots and pans
okay so you have my permission
to pull pots and pans out of the
cabinets and bang on them with spoons
and knives and things
you're still a kid and and and part of
being a kid is exploring the world
around you
and all all the way the laws of nature
influence that world
so take different pots of pans and hit
them with a spoon and they'll all sound
different
they'll sound different with different
spoons
some pans are aluminum some are steel
some are copper they'll sound different
and that's kind of a fun experiment and
most parents will say don't do that
you're getting them dirty stop doing
that you're making too much noise you
tell them that why did you have me in
the first place
because
you have to remind them that they didn't
have kids
so that they could keep having a neat
house
okay
because kids
make things messy and there's a reason
why they make things messy because
they're exploring the world around them
and so you have my permission
now if you get in trouble uh
i'm not going to be around i'm not going
to do better
but we have witnesses here right
okay
so
your meaning in life will be enhanced if
you're given as much freedom as you can
to explore the world
then when you get older
you will become so close to how the
world works that when a problem arises
that needs a solution you will say i
know how to solve that
i've been thinking about that before and
i've been thinking about that ever since
i was banging the pans on the kitchen
floor or ever since i jumped with two
feet into a puddle or ever since
i've walked up and out and caught
snowflakes in my mouth as i walked down
the street
did you do that today when it snowed
when was the last time you caught
snowflakes in your mouth
like a few
weeks ago okay
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna ask
that same question okay
[Applause]
i don't remember
you see the problem here okay
the brothers have forgotten how to
embrace nature
how to think about the natural world so
you will owe it to yourself and everyone
else
who will be
cured by some
medicine you may invent one day
you owe it to yourself and to everyone
else
to continue to stay curious
and by doing so
you will have created the meaning in
life
that others think
is waiting under a rock for them one day
and you would have made it happen all on
your own so thanks for your question in
your life what obstacles did you face
before you achieved success did
positivity help you in some ways and how
did you come up with the solution
wow
that's a good a good philosophical
question um
you know we all have adversity in our
lives i doubt if you really
you know if you know somebody any friend
or anybody that you talk to
there's no lack of adversity and by the
way that's good because it's what
teaches us how to get back up you fall
down you get back up it always happens
and
you know you get certain
gifts in life and you want to take
advantage of those
but you
i guess my advice on adversity and
success
would be
to
be proud not of your gifts
but of your hard work and your choices
so you know you may be the kinds of
gifts you get you know you might be
really good at math it might be really
easy for you that's a kind of gift
but practicing that math and taking it
to the next step
that could be very challenging and hard
and take a lot of sweat
that's a choice you can't really be
proud of your gifts
because they were given to you um you
can be grateful for them and thankful
for them um and but your choices
you choose to work hard you choose to do
hard things
those are choices that you can be proud
of you take crazy risks you bet you bet
your fortune on it and you seem to have
done that multiple times i mean almost
no one
can do that is that
can we have some of that secret source
can we put it into our education system
can someone learn from you it is truly
amazing what you've done oh thanks um
thank you well i i think there i do
think there's a good a good framework
for thinking is physics you know the
sort of first principles reasoning
generally that i think they're
um what i mean by that is
uh boil things down to their fundamental
truths and reason up from there as
opposed to reasoning by analogy um
through most of our life we we get
through life by reasoning by analogy
which essentially means kind of coughing
what other people do with slight
variations um and you have to do that
otherwise it's it's
mentally you wouldn't be able to get
through the day um but when you when you
want to do something new you you have to
you have to apply the the physics
approach get physics is really sort of
figuring out how to discover new things
that are counter-intuitive like quantum
mechanics it's really counterintuitive
so i think i think that's an important
thing to do and then also
to really pay attention to negative
feedback
and solicit it particularly from friends
this may sound like sort of simple
advice but it's
hardly anyone does that and it's
incredibly helpful
boys and girls watching
study physics
so how did you become so great
how did i become so great that's the
question well which class you are
studying fourth
what's your dream in life
i wanna become a singer
singer
this is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so i personally believe
you must have a dream
say
you must say i must have a dream i must
serve a dream
i must continuously acquire knowledge
continuously acquire knowledge i must
continuously acquire knowledge hard work
hard work hard work and perseverance and
perseverance one should not be of one
not afraid of problems not afraid of
problems that you'll be successful okay
i believe that opportunity looks a lot
like hard work
when i was 13 i had my first job with my
dad carrying shingles up to the roof
and then i got a job washing dishes at a
restaurant
and then i got a job in a grocery store
deli and then i got a job in a factory
sweeping cheerio dust off the ground
and i've never had a job in my life
that i was better than
i was always just lucky to have a job
and every job i had was a stepping stone
to my next job and i never quit my job
until i had my next job
and so opportunities look a lot like
work i want to be an entrepreneur when i
get alert but i don't know where to
start like what action should i be
taking right now as a kid the best way
to become something is to act like
something so you want to be an
entrepreneur start acting like one
meaning start a business start selling
things both will work or
find a mentor find the 18 19 20 21 year
old kind of entrepreneur in your
neighborhood and start helping her or
him out for free just to learn the
hustle to taste the game you've got to
put yourself in the position there's no
reading about entrepreneurship
do you know what a computer programmer
is
no
no
no when you're programming you're
teaching possibly the stupidest thing in
the entire universe a computer how to do
something programming is one of the only
things in the world that that you can do
where
you can sit down and just make something
completely new from scratch you know
whatever whatever you want it's really
not unlike kind of playing an instrument
or something or
you know or playing a sport
[Applause]
it starts out being very intimidating
but you kind of get the hang of it over
time
coding is something that can be learned
and
i know it can be intimidating
a lot of things are intimidating
but uh you know what isn't i was
obsessed with uh
maps when i was a when i was a kid
and cities specifically
so i taught myself how to program i had
a very clear goal of what i wanted to do
which is to
see a map of the city on my screen and
play with it put things on the map move
things around the map
see what was happening in the city how
it worked
how it lived how it breathed
the best early thing was actually using
software to decide when the classes in
my school would meet and that put me in
a position to decide
which girls were in my class
well i was in this after-school group
called the whiz kids and when people
found out they laughed at me and you
know all these things and i'm like man i
don't care i think it's cool and you
know i'm learning a lot and
some of my friends have jobs
[Music]
it's important for these kids
it should be mandatory
to be a citizen on this planet
to read and write code
i just think you have to start small
right and i think that's one of the
biggest misconceptions about computer
science and programming overall is that
you have to learn this big body of
information before you can do anything
you don't have to be a genius to know
how to code you need to be determined
addition subtraction uh that that's
about it you should probably know your
multiplication tables
you don't have to be a genius to code do
you have to be a genius to read do you
have to be a genius to do math no
no
i think if someone had told me that
software is really about humanity that
it's really about helping people by
using computer technology it would have
changed my outlook a lot earlier whether
you're trying to make a lot of money or
whether you just want to change the
world computer program is an incredibly
empowering skill to learn to be able to
actually
come up with an idea and then
see it in your hands and then be able to
press a button and have it be in
millions of people's hands i mean i
think we're the first generation in the
world that's really ever had that kind
of experience the programmers of
tomorrow are the wizards of the future
you know you're going to look like you
have magic powers compared to everybody
else i think it's amazing i think it's
the closest thing we have to a
superpower
great coders are today's rock stars
that's it
i say to the my girls
all of the time that your real work
is to figure out
where your power base is
and to work on the alignment of your
personality your gifts that you have to
give with the real reason why you're
here that's that's the number one thing
you have to do
is to work on yourself and to fill your
self up
and keep your cup full keep yourself
full now i used to be afraid of that
i used to be afraid particularly from
people who say oh she said she's so full
of hassan
she's so close herself and now i embrace
it i i consider it a compliment that i
am full
of myself
because you only when you're full
i'm full i'm overflowing my cup run it's
over i have so much i have so much to
offer and so much to give and i am not
afraid
of honoring myself you know it's
miraculous when you think about it
failure is part of life i mean
the difference for me though is i look
at failure as a stepping stone to
success it's a speed bump i know i'm
gonna fail um but it's not failure if
you learn something and so
gosh i've made so many mistakes i've
screwed so many things up but every time
i do it just becomes
it becomes a way for me to explain to
someone else what it takes you know it's
like here's what i've done i think i
have the ability to influence people
because i talk about my failures i talk
about all the things that mess me up but
i show people that i didn't let him stop
me and you don't need to stop you and i
think i think that's really the secret
matter and if everything you touched was
successful
i wasn't going to relate to people as
much no you'll be related and also it's
be total [ __ ] and everyone knows
and also you'd be bored silly i mean
think about it if you just said i want
this it happened i want this and it
happened you know
people don't value what they don't fight
for you know it's like you see kids
sometimes in it you know your parents
will say you're not going to value this
if you don't work for it and you're
kidding i'll value it just give it to me
right but it's true you know the things
we've worked the hardest for we value
the most so i think you know
the purpose of a goal is not getting it
anyway the purpose of goal you know is
what who you become who you become is
going to make you happy or who's going
to make you sad so um i'm not looking
for an effortless approach
there's no such thing one thing i really
like about you is you are unusually
fearless and
willing to go in the face of other
people telling you something is crazy
and i know a lot of pretty crazy people
you still stand out uh where does that
come from or how do you think about
making a decision when everyone tells
you this is a crazy idea or where do you
get the internal strength to do that
well first of all i'd say i actually
think i i think i feel feel fear quite
strongly
um
so it's not as though
i just have the absence of fear i've i
feel it quite strongly um
but
there are just times when
something is important enough you
believe in it enough that
you you do it in spite of fear
so speaking of important things like
people shouldn't think i i i should if
people should think well i feel fear
about this and therefore i shouldn't do
it um it's normal to be to feel fear
like you'd have to definitely something
mentally wrong if you didn't feel fear
um
so you just feel it and let the
importance of it drive you to do it
anyway
yeah you know actually something that
can be helpful is fatalism uh to some
degree um if you just if just accept the
probabilities um then
that diminishes fear
uh so um i'm starting spacex i thought
the odds of success were less than ten
percent
um
and i just accepted that actually
probably i would just lose
lose everything um
but that maybe would make some progress
if we could just move the ball forward
even if we died maybe
some other company could pick up the
baton and move and keep moving it
forward
um so that would still do some good
um yeah same with tesla i thought the
odds of a car company succeeding were
extremely low one night chris had gone
to bed
i had been struggling struggling
struggling we still had all the same
problems
i we started lean on the house still
facing bankruptcy still fighting like
crazy i was still unemployed
he still they still hadn't figured out
like the solution yet for the business
and i was about to turn off the tv and
there on the the tv there was this
rocket launching and i thought oh my
gosh
that
is
it
i am gonna launch myself out of bed like
a rocket ship like nasa right here had
launched me out of that bed and i'm
gonna move so fast that i don't think
i'm going to beat my brain
now here's a really interesting point um
i talk a lot about your instincts and
inner wisdom
and we can get into this a little bit
later but a lot of us talk about the
fact that you have a gut feeling but
what all this research that i've done
for the book and all the speaking that i
do what i've discovered that's
fascinating is actually when you set
goals when you have an intention on
something that you want to change about
your life
your brain helps you what it does is it
opens up a checklist
and then your brain goes to work trying
to remind you yeah of that intention
that you set and it's really important
to develop the skill and i say that word
purposefully the skill of knowing how to
hear that inner wisdom and that
intention kicking in
and leaning into it quickly so for me my
brain saying that's it right there move
as fast as a rocket mel
i wanted to change my life and i think
most people that are miserable
or that are that are really like dying
to be great and dying to have more we
want to change we want to
live a better life we want to create
more for our families we want to be
happier
the the desire is there
again it's about how do you go from
knowledge to action so the first thing
in the story that's important is
realizing that the answer was in me
and my mind was telling me pay attention
it could have also been the bourbon
manhattans that night
anyway the next morning the alarm goes
off and
um i pretended nasa was there
it's the stupidest story i literally
went five four three two one i counted
out loud and then i stood up
and i i'll never forget standing there
in my bedroom it was dark
it was cold
it was winter in boston
and for the first time in three months
i had beaten my habit
of hitting the snooze button
i couldn't believe it and i thought wait
a minute
counting backwards that is the dumbest
thing i've ever heard in my entire life
well the next morning i used it again
and it worked the next morning i used it
again and it worked the next morning i
used it again and it worked and then i
started to notice something really
interesting
there were moments all day long
all day long
just like that five second moment in bed
where i knew knowledge
what i should do
and if i didn't move within five seconds
my brain would step in and talk me out
of it
every human being has a five second
window might even be shorter
for you
you have about a five second window in
which you can move from idea to action
before your brain kicks into full gear
and sabotages
any change in behavior
because remember your brain is wired to
stop you from doing things that are
uncomfortable or uncertain or scary
it's your job to learn how to move from
those ideas that could change everything
into acting on them what would my advice
be to a driven and intelligent college
student or young person about to enter
the real world well i would be very
simple it would be focus on
learning instead of earning
and
that sounds cliche but i'll explain why
because if you want to make say a
million dollars a year 10 million
dollars a year instead of a hundred
thousand dollars a year
i would argue you probably don't want to
take
the hundred thousand dollar per year job
even if it's offered to you right out of
the gate i know that sounds like a lot
of money but
what i'm going to recommend is not
limited to finances you want to focus on
projects on companies on environments
where you can
learn lessons on someone else's bankroll
all right so let them pay for it and
view it effectively as
an apprenticeship so find
a situation where you can be
in the room with masters of a craft and
that could just be deal-making it could
be joining
a small company say fewer than 50 people
where you simply get to observe
one of the principles negotiating in an
industry that you don't even care
anything about right could be waste
management and you want to go into high
tech but if you sit in a room with
someone who's an absolute pro
at crafting deals negotiating getting
past no
those skills and maybe those
relationships
start to snowball
all right and this is what scott adams
the creator of dilbert would call
systems thinking so instead of being
wedded to the outcome of a given job
you are accumulating skills and
relationships
that transcend that job okay and if you
choose your environments well because as
i've said before and as people like
drew the ceo of dropbox as a friend have
said you're the average of the five
people you associate with most alright
so if you take
just a few years
have the patience the few years
to really develop core competencies that
allow you to craft your own reality and
life
negotiation deal making getting past no
etc learning how to pitch
how to get someone's attention in 30
seconds so that you can then create the
desire and ultimately ask for some type
of action
once you develop those
then
you can really just create the map for
the next decade in the next several
decades
so that would be it it would be learn
before you earn and it's never too late
to do that so i don't care if you're
coming out of college coming out of high
school 30 40 whatever it is
systems thinking focus on the
skills
and relationships first and then you can
just
create a blank check for how much money
you want to make if that is your goal
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video
because you are awesome if you want the
20 best pieces of advice every aspiring
entrepreneur needs to hear check the
video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there i say to the my girls
all of the time that your real work
is to figure out
where